اذا وعلى وقع الهجوم الاسرائيلي اغلقت
المتاجر في غزه ابوابها في انحاء القطاع
بينما تراجعت بشده حركه البيع والشراء في
الاسواق في ظل بقاء معظم اهالي غزه داخل
منازلهم
مميز
بلد ميته
سكره كلها لا بيع ولا شر ولا عمال قاعده
ما فيش حد بيتحرك من بيته كله نايم اليوم
عشان الوضع اللي احنا خايفين منه الكل
خايف الكل ملتزم البيوت بستنى رحمه من رب
العالمين
وانت شايف سمعنا كل الدائم مسكره كيف بدها
تطلع
اه فادي ما هيك شايف وضعها فش ولا بيعه
ولا شروه ولا اشي الكل ضابط وقاعد بستنى
بنتظر حل هالوضع الكل على الشاشات
التلفزيون الشعبي مسكرين حالهم
شغله من السوق مش ممكن
[موسيقى]
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات